babes I am on tour right now with the
guys tickets are available at
impracticaljokerslive.com a bunch of
cities up there cities always being
added this weekend
starting tonight we are in Niagara Falls
tomorrow March 10th at the Prudential
Center in Newark Saturday in Wallingford
Connecticut and Sunday at UBS arena in
Belmont later on in the month we got
Green Bay Milwaukee Rosemont then we're
heading over to Seattle Portland where
we head to the show so on and so forth
Bangor Maine extra show in Boston is
added all right now on
practicaljokerslive.com and the show is
on every single Thursday night 10
o'clock Eastern on TBS and TruTV all new
episodes season 10 check it out we love
you babe
I appreciate it New York City Radio City
Music Hall sold out in just 10 days on
September 22nd so we've added a show
September 23rd at the theater at Madison
Square Garden those tickets are on sale
at christycomedy.com New York City come
on out most of my shows thank you so
much are sold out the ones that aren't
are Fort Myers Florida coming up in
March 16th next week
um then we have March 29th one of the
shows at West Palm Beach has tickets
available uh Austin Texas April I'm
sorry no that's sold out April 13th San
Antonio Texas we have tickets available
The Late Show May 5th and buffalo has
tickets May 6th and Ithaca has tickets
and
um that's it so I appreciate it go get
the tickets in New York City theater at
MSG it's gonna be fun and we got special
guests and I'm not going to tell you
just gonna have to see it to believe it
and I have a show on Vice that's out now
it's called the super maximum retro show
every Tuesday 10 p.m Eastern Time
[Music]
no other
hey babe hey hey babe you think he talks
like that and he's like you just like he
doesn't hit in his regular life well I
think if you saw can I get a deposit
slip
on jaw rule he was in that documentary
about firefest yeah and I I noticed that
he didn't get he only got a little raspy
when he was backed into a corner with a
question like oh Ja Rule like you know
did you have anything to do with you
know the accounting that says like no I
didn't you know like very normally like
well we have we have a check here as
your name is
[Laughter]
um babe so here's the thing is I'm now I
fully decided I'm committed to going for
it you're like Father Guido Sarducci or
something like that it's crazy but what
I know like we're all about being but I
feel like I've made a choice and I feel
happy with this is I'm going to do this
till the wheels fall off and I'm just
gonna keep going and keep pushing until
I realize that I've went too far yeah
you're gonna do it till the wheels fall
off that old Cadillac yes that big tank
of a Cadillac that they used to blow up
in like Good Fellas but I think that's
who that's your like the personification
of that cattle but that but but is it
okay that I feel good like I love it bro
yeah right I love it yeah you do you and
and at different times in our life we
have different styles different feelings
yeah follow that that's what I'm trying
to do I have I feel like it's pulling
something out of you as well yes because
I feel like I'm I have more fun on stage
I'm free I'm happier but I do think the
glasses I'm gonna start doing the
glasses every other week okay I'm not
gonna do the glasses every week yeah
because then it almost becomes again a
uniform yeah then it becomes like I have
to wear these right so for the next step
you put some glasses on stage I do the
glasses all day do you ever do sets
without even mentioning the glasses
though I used to you know very you know
same bits you know Jeffrey Dahmer these
are my dads or whatever but now when I
went on stage two or three nights ago I
did not address it that's with the [__]
right there and I just went out there
and I and then that's you right that's
who I am you're not being like I'm
trying these out yeah like makes a good
joke the clothes I noticed I've taken a
turn now did you have these are you
finding stuff in your closet that fit
the bill or did you go out and do like a
quick once over and get a new like retro
uh wardrobe I said well this shirt this
shirt I said I want to dress like
homeless pimp today and because it's got
a zipper at the bottom this is actually
called Paul Fredericks and there was an
ad on Instagram that I bought this shirt
for like 50 bucks on Instagram bought it
and and I actually what I actually have
been doing though is going back I've
been actually researching I've been
going back into Old family photos that I
have and seeing what my dad used to wear
in the early 90s late 80s things that
you know he was not necessarily like he
was just the everyday fashion he wasn't
necessarily A fashionable guy and then
you know so he had a shirt not a shirt
like this but there's another there's a
sweater I bought I saw a similar sweater
he had I saw that sweater bro yeah
that's nice yeah that's the throwback
right there yeah Throwbacks baby you
know um Carlo Colucci is a Big Brand
I've been using going on this site
called grailed where they you know
grilled grilled yeah of course so
grilled so they which by the way they're
shipping their clothes from the Ukraine
so I don't know how that's possible I
don't know how they're getting more
Ukraine grilled every time I order a
piece from grailed it says it is your
package is in Kiev and I get a message
from FedEx that says due to
um uh whatever circumstances we made up
we can't guarantee the safety of your
package I said I bet you can't yeah
let me get this shirt and then like
right at checkout it's like uh due to
ballistic missiles trying yeah package
maybe three to five days late no um yeah
I don't know about that but I'll tell
you what I I uh I got some stuff for you
man because I was my nickname is Sally
retro because the only way I dress for
like four years of college was is with
all old old clothes like that shirts
like that I was when and also in the in
the mid 90s there was this like swing
movement okay not like have sex with
your friend's neighbor like you can if
you want to you can but it was like uh
like swing like music dancing the whole
that Revival it was that swing yeah well
I was always heavy into that stuff but
and then so a lot of that kind of
clothing came out and like that would
have a lot of these things the whatever
I saved but from college I have [__]
leisure suits and stuff why did you
decide to then get out of the Sally
retro phase and go into more now you
know Sally present yeah it was just you
know it was just you grow out of it
to Street Wear right now I used to be a
little bit more buttoned up I just go
where the fashion takes me see what
that's what I like is you go where the
fashion takes you which is the name of
this episode and I think that I think
that a lot of people I was never a guy
first of all I don't know much about I'm
not a fashion guy I just said I'm just
gonna go with what I what makes me feel
comfy and I feel comfortable in this
shirt and I feel like I'm I feel like
I'm playing for the Golden State
Warriors and the chain is that new the
chain is new it is yeah this I just I
said you know you went to a jeweler for
that no is that costume real uh what
does costume mean uh not real like fake
jewelry well I got it from a site called
Jackson so I don't know if that's what
did you pay like it didn't say it was
carrot like 14 karat gold or it was 220
it's probably plated or costume I don't
know yeah it plays very nice I like it
yeah and you I see you wore the the
black
guinea tea yes I did on Denise now this
is very uh it's just Bronx Tale yeah
slash uh Daddy-o yeah well my mother
shout out my mom told me this is an
exact quote from my mom because I I was
wearing a um a black guinea tea uh last
week when I was just at the house with
my daughter and my mother said she goes
you know honey you look good in the
guinea tease now you finally got your
clavicles back I said well clavicle is a
bone never lost it if I had no clavicles
that my head would roll off my shoulders
she goes but that's what she said she
goes you finally got your clavicles back
I think what she meant was you've lost
enough weight now where your shoulders
look your shoulders
she finally did say you got your
clavicles back I was like okay how
Chrissy got his clabs back how did
Chrissy got his clams back yeah and so
and so she got a group back and then
there's a sequel yeah she got it what
happened in the second one she still had
it she lost it again I had to get it
back again
was it someone else that got that groove
back in the second one
shout out Stella shout out Stella Got a
good back shout out Whitney Houston if
you remember the song from that was
Shoop Shoop uh
um no not shuparoop it was Whitney
Houston's Shoop song
um well Shoop is
what is Whitney Houston's song for
Stellar got her groove back there was
wasn't it uh
no that was from The Bodyguard okay
oh what about oh oh I know I mean it's
not right but it's no no no no that no
this it's Waiting to Exhale what's the
song uh How Stella Got a group it
doesn't that start with a
H doesn't it does it an exhale
a movie
it's waiting text hell a movie yeah
by the way
uh waiting awaiting textile is a move
this is okay
Whitney Houston had a song from for
Waiting to Exhale not in Stellar cutter
back I apologize I mix up seller got a
groove back and well maybe it's both
Angela bass and that's not because
that's just genuinely I just made a
mistake that's all right and it happened
so pick yourself up over it
something I've noticed about Sal and
here's why I think Sal is um you know a
human that's just kind of uh uh
just does things the right way uh little
nuances about Sal are you know when you
get to know him you realize like okay
you have to start living in kind of
house you know you know what wwsd what
would Sal do okay Sal is here now I
would assume for two hours in gonna be a
few hours in New York City uh he brought
his lunch from home which is by the way
big thing to do big big thing to do but
what what most people don't do and what
they wish they did and they don't do but
with Sal now I've seen the second time
he's done Sal comes if he's going to be
in the city for a day
he brings his toothbrush with him and
Sal brushes his teeth in public places
and that's why he's fit he's fresh and
he has good teeth
yeah I didn't always do that but I
started yeah well I think it's one of
those big improvements I do it in the
day and in the night but now I bring the
toothbrush with me because you never
know literally all disease enters
through the mouth they're not no disease
is going to get through your mouth it's
too clean nah now with Crest on the case
yeah Shadow Crest shout out Colgate all
the big ones all the big ones Tom's is
trying to get in there all natural
sometimes it doesn't work the deodorant
suspect yeah the toothpaste pretty good
I gotta be honest with you I love
everything Tom stands for how they give
back the shoes every time you use that
deodorant I smell worse wait Tom's Shoes
is the same as Tom's deodorant and it's
too pissed I would think that their
vanity is shaking her head no vanity
who's very plugged in the charity
movement yeah um
[Laughter]
the deodorant
uh one is Thompson Maine and one's Tom
Kenny bunk Maine sounds like a fun place
is that what it is it says the company
is based in Kenny Kenny bunk Maine isn't
that something with presidents I was
just to hear that like can a book
Kennebunkport Maine
Kennebunkport Kenny bunk Maine Maine is
a beautiful state that I feel like we
don't talk about enough and I'd like to
dedicate more time to it Poland Springs
what it means to be from Maine I'm going
to Bangor Maine really yes sir April
27th I'll be there on tour never been
Bangor Maine Banger Banger maybe next
night Boston and the next night Boston
added the show April 28th Northeast uh
uh Sally uh Sally Northeast uh Sally New
England
um Banger have you been I've never been
to Bangor Maine too fun here's some
facts about Maine the capital is Augusta
it's um it's you know of course our most
northern state Augusta Maine Augusta
Maine is the capital of of Maine
um it was almost uh uh Canada almost
engulfed Maine and just took Maine as
its own state but we fought hard for
Maine because we wanted their lobsters
and their trees and they got a lot of
people before Canada no we didn't fight
Canada but in Canada wanted to take
Maine they wanted Maine but who would
they tell would they send an email oh we
kind of out at some point in history I
forgot who the president was at that
time at some point in history one of the
presidents said you can't have Maine
they were like can we have Maine and
they were like no no we're going to give
me okay we're gonna We're Gonna Keep Me
and Maine was like we don't whatever
whoever we're not getting in yeah yeah
they're like we're just having fun yeah
what goes on in Maine seafood seafood
um a lot of uh uh skiing summer a lot of
people sleep on Maine in the summer
Maine is one of the most beautiful
Wildlife there's moose up there it's
like an it's like a natural Preserve the
Moose come over from Canada yeah that
that's the thing they don't care the
most don't give a [__] about your
borders moose don't give a [__] it's
like a honey badger they don't give a
[__] let me ask you a question if a
moose was in your purview you're running
moose is dangerous yeah I'm also [__]
you up you don't want to run I I'm just
gonna take a guess I think that a moose
is I think that you need to stay
still for a moose am I wrong on that
let's watch this one there are so big
moose are so big they're like
prehistoric have you ever seen that
video The Moose walking down the street
in Alaska and it's it's twice as big as
a Chevy Suburban yes yes
let's see this woman get attacked by one
I saw a moose in uh Colorado like I
swear to God I swear to Christ I saw
moose in Colorado on the street here
in the United States no no in the United
States yeah I saw a moose I think it was
it was yeah we were out no it wasn't
Colorado where the hell was I Sundance
Utah we were in Utah uh uh Sundance Utah
and we saw a moose and they had it all
cautioned off and I swear to Christ it
was a moose sitting in front of a Barnes
and Nobles
it was just sitting there it was a
female moose and they had to call it
like environment protection was there to
try to convince the Moose
you know he just made me laugh too you
did what most of my mom does you make
everything plural because I think it's
Barnes and Noble he was like he was in
front of that Barnes and Nobles yeah my
mom does that she said we're going to
Target
wait did we see oh oh it played we
didn't we didn't see it I want to see it
here we go okay here's this is a moose
attacking a woman in Anchorage Alaska
which is all which is not the capital G
oh my God
I think you just stopped her look
I don't even see the woman
you see the woman
not that I see gender
the lady goes hey hey
wait wait wait wait wait wait get up I
don't it's hard to tell what's going on
here but a moose a moose is dangerous a
moose is known as dangerous right like
if you see a moose I was clear run I
think that it's one of them I I can't
remember it's either a bear a moose or a
T-Rex you have to stay still maybe all
the above a moose right is it a man
is a female Musa moose like do they all
have the antlers or they don't have it
when it's a baby what's a baby I think a
male moose has the antlers a female
moose doesn't have the atlas that's what
I would think but I've never seen a
moose without antlers that would look
silly the moose that was in front of the
Barnes and Nobles didn't have antlers
and it had very very skinny legs
what about this you ready for this tell
me nine what's the difference nine feet
and the front hoof width is five inches
for a prime ball four inches for a cow
okay so the bowl by the way did you know
that did you ever realize that Sal that
every time we eat a meat we're eating a
female cows are female
Bulls are male so you're never eating
bull meat you're only eating cow meat I
think I've realized that a couple times
in my life and keep forgetting so now I
never think of that when I eat it you
just reminded me that that's the case
and that's insane that's insane because
that that I don't know why the feminists
don't talk about that a little bit we
only eat the food we only eat the feed
every cows and how is that fair unless
it's a unless it's Bice is it bison
bison but that might be female bison
where how many female animals do we need
to eat wait do we don't eat bull I don't
think we eat both what do we do a bowl
is just used to impregnate cows
you're [__] me right now I'm telling
you bull does nothing males intended for
meat are routinely castrated uh
okay uh but this is poultry
I think that we're only in female cows
how about this I'll take it one step
further what is the difference between a
sheep and a lamb oh I'll do this all day
long because I got no clue also a goat
a sheep and a lamb no clue they both go
bad
I don't know what a [__] goes bad yeah
but a goat doesn't have goco
but a goat like a I think there's just
female goats and male goats here sheep
bird slam the word lamb is ref see Lamb
is a young baby sheep so when you eat
lamb when you eat venison you're eating
the baby uh you're just eating the baby
when I say lambswool they're shearing
that sheep when it's young they don't
say sheep's wool right the word sheep is
used to refer to a domestic animal
that's kept for its wool
where in March it's coming in like a
lion going out like a lamb
what is that what does that imply that
lamb is gentle that the weather
I think that what it's implying is is
that yeah ferocious weather coming in
ferocious just like rain a lot of rain
coming out
more subtle like a lamb that's what I
think it means I know I you know there's
no I didn't have any point to that it's
just Lamb of God take away the sins of
the world
God had a lamb and this lamb
I say stuff growing up in Catholicism
that never really clicks the Lamb of God
takes away the Lamb of God take away the
sins of the world grant us peace yeah
good grant us pizza is there a powerful
pet lamb running around up there that we
didn't really identify why don't we use
a lamb more like in you know like
therapy who who's the Lamb of God
there's only one
God had a lamb God had a little baby
lamb well God's so old that must be a
sheep by now we'll have to have grown up
right God had a baby sheep God had a
baby well no baby a baby sheep is called
a lamb right so you think sometimes you
would hear baby sheep you take away the
sins of the world but you don't grant us
peace but you don't but you don't oh
this [__] yeah who's this [__] Lamb
Chop oh Lamb Chop yeah Lamb Chop play
along
but that lady's not alive right uh she I
mean she had a perm 40 years ago she had
lamb chops play along half hour
preschool television show was on from 92
to 98 this is before your time I mean
after your time yeah I remember her
though because you can't forget her she
just got a hysterectomy name what's her
name oh she died at 65 at night oh she
died while she was doing the show
like live
like with her hand in the lamb
that what's that name again I'm actually
hoping Sherry Lewis she was the I I
remember this woman from my childhood
right don't you guys she was born
Phyllis Naomi hurwitz now why did she
need to change her name from Phyllis to
Sherry why I think that back in that
time like they didn't think like a name
like Phyllis Horowitz would sell but
Shari Lewis would I guess if Sherry
Lewis just more like you know more
common nay I don't know exactly why but
it it just it seemed like the right move
for them then and Sharon Lewis I think I
just was married and divorced two or
three times I just saw that and I saw
something in there that always baffles
me you ever go on these Wikipedia pages
and you'll see the person's spouse and
sometimes it's like like six divorces
and you'll see them get divorced in like
82 and then married in 83. that's such a
quick turnaround like you do you think
that you know you want to marry someone
coming off a divorce in less than under
a year you're wed again some people it's
a red flag it's a red flag and some
people they can't wait to get married
that's all they want to do is they
believe in marriage and they rather than
just being in a relationship with
boyfriend girlfriend they need to get
married right but I think that's
happening less and less in our society
though now because you mean to tell me
that you're coming off a divorce and
you're dealing with all that baggage and
soul-searching and healing and whatnot
and you're ready to make a U-turn locate
someone that you think you want to spend
the rest of your life with and make the
commitment right immediately not even
like all right you might be the new one
I don't know if you're a rebound you
might be let's take it slow we'll get
married in a couple years right you're
meeting someone saying this is the one
again and getting married in under the
one year from the divorce they get a
little term called Lovestruck okay they
get Love Struck and then when you get
Love Struck like that you kind of get
into the Trap can those people that get
mad I guarantee you when they get
married and divorced within a year they
will go they're the same they're going
to fall into the same trap within five
years and it's a pattern it's Behavior I
mean think about how many people that
you meet they said oh my this is my
fourth wife this is my third husband
right people aren't like that yeah I
don't think I think it's happening less
and less yeah now but that's I mean a
big thing back then people had three
four five husbands I couldn't have that
I could have one husband tops yeah you
don't want all that I just wrote an
article about a guy who had three wives
but they're like in regular Society
they're not like Mormons or anything and
he's just like I love you love me he's
like we love it there's no I thought
that was illegal black dude three white
chicks
I probably that's probably not illegal
that's but that's not anything sounds
like a porn yeah I I um yeah I I they
were genuine like and I'm like how do
you get into that scenario what about
what about and I and and I mean think
about the stress and drama what about
the guy who's got a wife and then a
girlfriend with a family on the side
what about how does that guy live his
life I knew a guy you ready yes
[Music]
yeah that was fun yeah
um I knew a guy um
what I'm about to tell you is 100
000 percent true it sounds like it could
be made up it is as factual as facts can
be when people say facts facts facts
this is facts it's not like Seinfeld
talking about Keith Hernandez where he's
like here I go I meet this guy this
great guy good
facts
I knew a guy who well I didn't know him
direct but I knew I knew of the story
facts
I didn't know him directly
his wife pregnant okay which is that
happens
allegedly he had his wife pregnant okay
he got then his girl on the side
pregnant okay they were due to give
birth he ejaculated in both he
ejaculated right time small window small
window everything went ahead somehow
because guess what he must have been
near the Lamb of God and the Lamb of God
gave him the baby sheep of God baby
sheep of God fertility okay he had he
had both these women pregnant at the
same time with the same due date Sal
same due date same due date you ready
for this ready for this
went into the hospital the same day
three rooms apart
yes this can't be real this is [__]
real still was trying to hold it back
from each other stayed with his wife
when his wife you you know how do you
know of this guy it's my friend's friend
that went through this
he would go with his wife oh that's
that's it's that's sad go with his wife
yeah and be with her and whatever baby
push push and then go into the other
room and try to you know deal with that
the side you got the hospital staff the
hospital knew and because they didn't
want to upset anyone just dealt with it
just just it's not their business their
their business is to get the baby out
safe so they knew that putting if they
found out about it that would put both
women in distress distress mode wow
I don't know how you deal with that I
don't know how you process that and he's
playing with fire and now what happened
did it ever come to to light it was all
found out of course it was all found out
uh everything was discovered my hair
matches your shirt is what it does okay
his wife divorced him his wife divorced
him uh
I mean [__] women can't just accept
[__] his wife divorced him uh his wife
divorced him the other girl he tried to
stay with the other girl baby's a
miracle for a little bit two babies
she's unhappy with a miracle yeah and uh
and and last I heard he was dating his
boss's daughter
I don't know man yeah it's just people
like to be in that drama they like to be
in that drama and who do we save the
drama for for your mama
your mama for your mama everybody's mom
for your mama even if your mom is dead
I'm Gonna Save her for her dead ass body
yeah
did you did you ever say your mama to
someone in Earnest in wait did you ever
like get caught up and you were I mean
we're heated and you said to someone
your mama in Earnest
no but that would be funny right to say
like your mother and like that's your
actual yeah your mother oh people used
to say that your mother your mother yeah
and then then it's just like fill in the
blanks after that right they never
really you didn't have to finish it your
mother was the insult right like your
mother and then imagine anything bad
about your mother right right right your
mother your mother yeah people used to
say that one time I was on the train one
time I was on the train
I was like 15 years old and I heard
these kids were arguing they were
friends these kids were arguing and
somebody and one of them said to the
other he goes yo man you smell like a
thousand asses in one room
and then the other kid said your mother
but he said you smell like a thousand
houses in one room that's great man it
yeah kids are people gonna say your
father means nothing means nothing yeah
your daddy your dad yeah it doesn't mean
anything because and that's and there's
sexism in society right we're only
eating female animals we're only dissing
the mothers everything's about we need
to start we should start doing your
father and we should start eating the
male version of the animal
oh my God speaking of animals I had
a dead raccoon in my backyard it had
eaten poison from the house next door
and it was crawled up in a ball like
that and I literally and my daughter
comes back to the background she goes
dad there's a sloth and
New York
I was like where do we live in the
rainforest
I was like there's no sloths upside down
she goes dad that's a sloth
I feel like it's probably like ice age
or some [__] yeah I was like wait what
and I go back there and it's a raccoon
and sound for the life of me she's like
Dad there's a red tail lemur
there's a lemur of sort that's a woolly
mammoth that sounds like Ray Romano dead
in the yard
so so
um so I I you know Jazz was like you
know you have to it's literally in like
it's by the kids swing set like yeah and
so I was like oh I went out there you
know you you know if you would have
caught that you would have caught it
being like
yeah it was bad because that's where it
died right there but right before it got
there it was walking yeah and it was
like yeah and then and then because the
house next door is being demolished so
they put poison out which I don't know
why they need to do that when you
demolish a house why do you need to put
poison and try I know because I know
that they'll be mice and Vermin but what
do you got to poison them why can't you
just let them go out into the wild yeah
because if you're demolishing the house
there's going to be so much Construction
and building that
those things aren't staying there right
you need to you need to maybe you don't
want to just just demolishing of a house
provide some type of cover for these
Vermin I don't know I I have no only
when the house is on but then they they
extract yeah that's what I'm saying I
didn't understand like what is the point
of having all this poison around I mean
maybe because they don't want mice to go
into other people's houses I don't know
but I was like my kids have so many
crumbs all over the house we're getting
mice one way or another right but both
have a mouse in the house we had a mouse
last year oh did you yeah we found mouse
droppings but then we got our kitchen
redone and you know it's it's over now
you ever have a mouse in the house I
know in my grandparents I saw a mouse I
freaked the [__] out of me though right
it was cute and stuff but it would Dart
yeah and and then well the thing is I
don't the mouse mice are fine I I can
deal with my it's just it's just the
mouse poop having a little baby it's
just it's so toxic oh yeah you can't you
can't you know if she the mouse pisses
or shits on the toys yeah because all my
kid does you know she's in the face
right now she just positions anything in
her mouth so so so
um you know John's like you have to go
get a garbage bag well the first thing I
did because I said I looked at it I was
like this is going to be tough I called
3-1-1 was it a large sucker it was it
was a lodge okay it was large and and
and I I saw I called 3-1-1 I swear to
God I call through one I said hey you
know um how are you I was like I have a
um a dead raccoon on my property so is
there someone who could come here and
you know pick it up she was like is it
private property I was like uh yes I'm
just being exactly how this is exactly
how this woman talked uh I said yeah she
goes we ain't coming on private property
and I said you know uh I totally
understand I said but there's a dead
animal in my backyard what I'm supposed
to do she said you're supposed to go get
a black garbage bag put on gloves put it
in the black garbage bag and then put it
out in your sanitation and the
sanitation department will take the
animal and I was like okay I was like
but what if it's diseased what if
there's I've never discarded of a dead
animal before she goes I can't help you
baby
[Laughter]
pick it up she goes she goes here's what
you do you should have did what shoveled
it put it right in the middle of the
street be like hello this is raccoon in
front of my house but even that like it
was stiff stiff as a board yeah she was
like take it up a Bloom Cafe yeah and so
and so she's like here's what you have
to do child hang out with me dial Bloom
Cafe and she said take it up with them
and so but she said she goes here's what
you do she goes she goes put on gloves
this is all true with Uncle she goes put
on gloves she goes yo quiero hey babe
you've been using Babble that's what
language learning app on your phone they
have bite-sized lessons everything suit
your needs they have over 14 languages
it's not done by Ai No it's done by
linguist babe yep and whether you want
to communicate with a new friend or
you're going on vacation or you just
want to brush up yes babbles for you
babble's for you and plus it comes with
a 20-day money-back guarantee so you can
start your new language learning today
and if you don't like it after 20 days
which you will you will get a 20-day
back guarantee but the catch is is they
send you the form in the language you're
trying to learn you really got to brush
up on it so that's a joke just kidding
they will give you full money back in
whatever currency you prefer that's it
that's also another joke it's U.S
currency I would assume okay
um right now you can get up to 55 off 55
off Cinco e-sync that's almost half your
subscription when you go to babble.com
hey babe that's b a b b e l.com slash
hey babe 55 55 off your subscription
babble language for life
let me ask you a question yes you know I
have two kids yes okay and I'm thinking
about legally changing their names yes
oh my God I'm thinking about legally
changing their names yeah what do you
have for names for them for one in the
other I name one hello I name one fresh
that's what I was thinking America's
number one kid yes and they're Latinos
so you can also go Olaf Fresca same
thing I love that too hellofresh it's
America's number one meal kit first
that's what it is and that's why and
that's what I love about it so much
because I mean I love everything that's
number one in America I love the name
yeah the name is really on point you
don't forget the name it's cheery it's
light it you get fresh in the name hello
is kind of cute you go oh hello friends
yeah I love fresh oh my God yeah now let
me tell you something first of all it's
made with fresh wholesome ingredients
which we love here at this show because
this is a fresh wholesome podcast
delivered to your door no lines no booby
hassles just great tasting meals you can
whip up and enjoy in the comfort of your
own home powering up with protein is
easier than ever now with hello fresh
all you gotta do is get the protein
smart the protein smart meals I got the
bean chili they have the creamy Dijon
dill chicken 30 grams of protein you're
gonna get Jack customized uh and select
your meal so you could swap out your
protein whatever it is you could do a
veggie dish yeah you can upgrade to
organic chickens or organic ground beef
yeah now I did listen here's the thing
is here's the thing with hellofresh is
theirs is another company that when they
give us a deal we get excited and then
on our ride home we often question how
the hell does that company make money
because it seems like you just give all
their products away for free give this
kind of deal it seems like how do you
where's the because it's insane listen
to this deal if you go to hellofresh.com
right now and put in hey babe60. so
hellofresh.com hey babe60 and use the
code hey babe60 you're going to get 60
almost half plus free shipping
60 off plus free shipping hellofresh.com
hey babe60 use the code hey babe 60 60
off plus free shipping Sal tell me how
they do it I don't know but it's not
America's number two meal kit s
America's number one meal kit this is
all true we're long she goes put on
gloves she goes put put a couple layers
of clothing on you she was like
take two or three black garbage bags
wrap them up she goes grab turn them
inside out grab the animal with the bags
and then flip the bags on there just
like you I swear I swear this is on
speaker Jazz she goes just like you're
picking up doo doo after your dog
he goes it's the same thing and you put
it in and then it's gonna be fine and
the sanitation department will throw it
out and I was like uh all right so I
said you know what I'll do it all right
gave me confidence to do it I went out
there I she gave you the company she
actually gave me the conference to do it
I I she gave me the confidence to keep
these glasses on right and and I I went
out there to do it my whole family's
watching me I got within this distance
of it like say there and I went and I
could not do it yeah because something
comes over you I couldn't do it I
couldn't it was like my body was frozen
and Jazz was like do I have to do it I
was like I genuinely cannot do this yeah
because because you're gonna feel the
through the bag you're gonna feel its
bones and fur and stiffness and that's
literally what I suggested here's my
suggestion I said what if what it's the
winter time Jazz I said what if I know
this is crazy but just because I can't
do it you can't do it what if we just
get a bunch of you know old towels put
it over the body let it rot it'll be a
skeleton and then in the summertime
we'll take care of it that's not gonna
work she was like it's gonna smell it's
gonna be disgusting it'll explode yeah
get it off our property she was like
this your daughter's play there right
get it and and she was like what the
[__] are you doing yeah so I did the
only thing I could do I called our guy
Sean the contractor and Sean the
contractor who is a real man came over
and he picked it up with his bare
[__] hands and put it in a garden I
swear to God he's a real man or not
that's not that's not a smart man he
picked it up by the tail he had Purell
in his pocket he gave her two pumps done
over he went back to doing the floor the
dead raccoon he pee around his hands
after he picked it up bare handed he was
like Wow and he said to me because Chris
don't worry about he did the right thing
I didn't want you to hurt yourself I was
like okay
you think I'm the type of man that can't
be hurt by a dead raccoon wow I couldn't
pick up a live chicken once really it
was very it's very uh unsettling to try
to pick up a live chicken because the
way they're running around they're
aggressive it's like foreign to me it's
just a foul you know and and it's
essentially not a it's a wild animal you
don't have to bring patriotism into this
sure right but you know it's Got Claws
it's erratic it's it's it's it's it's
it's it's it's it's it's not it's not
domesticated right uh you know and and
it it's weird they're weird birds are
weird but but but so it's amazing like
and they they don't want to be picked up
no and you know they're light but
they're not but in the feathers but
there's bones so there's beaks think
about like our you know Grandma you know
especially from the Latino side like you
know the Puerto Rican grandma abolita
Yeah grab it cut its [__] throat eat
it for dinner that night that night like
a goddamn Apple why the hell not like
Ozzy Osbourne yeah yeah I think you're
gonna pick up a chicken no I don't think
I couldn't pick up an I don't even like
to pick up a cat or even dogs I don't
like to pick up animals I'm not and I
don't hate animals but I somebody's
saying Birds aren't real what does that
mean
The Conspiracy Theory online that uh
some kids saying that all birds are not
real they're drones something along
those lines it's a conspiracy theory
some people think it's a joke satirical
yeah
well it is it would be interesting if we
are in a simulation and an advanced
Society like some people think we are
that birds could be a thing that was
like like you know when you watch The
Hunger Games it's like all that stuff
looks real but they were kind of
creating an idea where it's like what if
Birds aren't just manufactured in a lab
how would you ever seen I've never seen
a bird give birth
no well well you've yeah well they come
out of the egg too I had one for
breakfast yeah yeah they come out of
that and then you ever see the mom feed
it's wild she like throws food right
down that gullet really she's like
dude once that bird is like can do this
it's like all right take it easy it's
done and that kind of comes back let me
ask you Chris Rock had a good bit in his
latest special about that birth control
control Chris Rock had a good bit about
that what
um one of the bits was I thought Chris
Rock's latest special that the Netflix
nice actually had two really good bits
which I like the the bird bit the the
one bit was about how um how he uh I
think this was Chris Rock did he do the
bit about
um how you know where humans were the
only ones that have to raise our kids
for 18 years we're like a bird on day
two and he just [__] goes fly
[__] yeah yeah and then I liked
his we were talking before I liked his
you know the premise of a corporation
being woke is done by a lot of comics
but his joke specifically about it I
thought was unique where he said you
know Lou lemon's selling 100
yoga pants that are not racist yeah he
goes you hate somebody goes I'd rather
buy a 25 pair of racist yoga pants
that's when you walk say the N word I
was like that that was a good [__]
[__] that was a good bit yeah that was
a good bit yeah I didn't I didn't uh but
you know I I but those but those bits
how did why did I start talking about
that oh because uh oh the bird the uh oh
we're talking about birds let me ask
your question yes you can come back as
an animal talk to me about it it could
be any animal do you want the power of
flight do you want to be a turtle and
live 130 years do you want to be a bear
nobody can [__] you up right you want to
be a dog because his man's best friend
great life but it's only 14 years like
12 years like what do you what do you
what do you choose no I actually would
think I would want to be I think if I
could be any animal what I would I do
think I'd like to have flight because a
lot of you know some people say oh would
you want to be a shark would you want to
be a whale I don't want to only see the
ocean I want to have the opportunity to
see the ocean and the land so what I
think what I would nobody see it more
than a bird and here's the thing nobody
seen more than a bird and here's the
thing is I love you know me I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm New York City I love New York
City I want everything to be about New
York City I love this city so much I'd
come back as a pigeon
oh wow as a New York pigeon oh wow I'm
gonna see the city I'm gonna be in and
out of the city I'm gonna be cool I'm
gonna be thugged out I'm you know I'm
gonna be a little grimy I'm gonna be
like kind of in and out like I'm gonna
be a New York pigeon
um and just be careful I'll be safe I'll
look both ways you know I'll try not to
hit it by bus okay yeah yeah you ever
kill a pigeon
I drove over a pigeon once yeah it
didn't move in time no they didn't move
in time something else I hit a cat too
once I did too you did right you ever
hit a deer I killed a cat never hit a
deer you sure the cat's dead I watched
it die I told you this no I I hid it and
then I put it in a box it was blind not
even blind had no eyeballs
because you knocked them out no no
it was a neighborhood cat and it ran
across the street and I hidden people
sitting in front of the house I thought
I told the story on with the car you hit
it I was going to Palmer video to rent a
video with my high school girlfriend and
my little sister in the back seat and I
was driving a Plymouth K Reliant car uh
it was a brown car I was going down
Lyndhurst Avenue and the cat jutted out
and I slammed on the brakes and I looked
and I saw it in the rearview like like
being like ah [__] like I messed up
first of all heart sank got out of my
car immediately ran up to it people were
in the sitting it was the summertime
people sitting outside their front Lawns
which was a great time by the way I hope
that this summer in New York the old
ladies the old people get the launchers
at the front lawn a destination please
there used to be a concert on my block
called tuneful Tuesdays where they would
have bands come and play 60s music in
the CH in the Ridgewood Savings Bank
parking line all the old ladies would
sit out I love it yeah it was great I
love when people sat in front and
everyone saw
[Music]
and if you want to go back to that life
watch super Max from retro show on Vice
TV 10 p.m on uh what day Tuesdays okay
just came out that's right check your
local listings the dead cat
yeah they gave me a box and a blanket
and they said you did my cat in a box
a cat in the Box girl
[Music]
it's my cat and our box okay that's like
a female version my cat my box got it
yeah anyway they said you didn't do
anything wrong the cat is a neighborhood
cat that we all take care of but it's
blind it ran out in front of you and I
put the cat in a blanket oh man wait so
you did pick up a dead animal then or a
dying animal I picked it up or someone
picked it up I don't think you picked it
up because if you can't because you and
I are very similar like that I'm telling
you when you get and you're a dead body
or you it you something freezes and I
feel like you have that same freeze I
felt the worst I've ever felt hitting
this cat and it was still alive and
right by where the video store was
literally down the block was a vet block
and I went to the vet and I I didn't
tell you the story was it purring was it
like bleeding out like what what wasn't
doing anything it was laying there kind
of like it was dying maybe in shock
it was terrible and I went into the vet
and I didn't want to tell them that I
hit it right and so I was just like I
saw the guy in front of me hit this cat
and I you know I just wanted to do the
right thing and I think you know
obviously and he looked at the cat he's
like we're gonna have to put the cat
down he knew yeah and he goes um you
could tell he didn't believe me and he
thought I hit it and he was right and uh
he goes well we're gonna have to put the
cat down I said okay well you know God
bless everything and he said he goes
we incur the cost of this we literally
are not sitting here today having the
fun we're having having the success
we're having having as beautiful skin as
you have without ship station
if you're running an online business and
you don't have ship station then you're
not really running a business right
you're not running a business that's
profiting I'll tell you that much
because ship station literally makes the
hassle the everyday hassle of sending
out orders so simple ship station does
it all for you they make ship happen you
use it across all platforms whatever you
make sure you get the lowest price
possible I don't care this was it you
couldn't do this before us I don't
believe this is this is revolutionary in
my opinion the other day the other day
vanitya came into the office she was 20
minutes away I said how'd you get it she
said ship station one two three in a
landscape where free and fair shipping
is the norm it can be hard for smaller
e-commerce businesses to compete keep
yourself competitive with ship station
yeah and you get up to 84 off I was born
in 1984. 84 off off you are USPS and UPS
rates the USPS I like it but it just
throws me because it's a new term USPS
no United States Postal Service I think
it's been around for quite some time but
the point though is that they use every
Marketplace on One dashboard it's so
much better than you you're not going
you're just going right there literally
98 of companies that stick with chip
station for a year become customers for
life what does that tell you right now
all you have well it tells me that I
must go to shipstation.com put in the
promo code hey babe because I'm going to
get a free 60-day trial when I do that
free 60 days all you got to do is go to
shipstation.com put in the promo code
hey babe I mean what else are you
waiting for I'm not you gotta give you a
smack if you don't do it that's right
and I would deserve it
so if you'd like to donate anything
to put toward it and I was like well I
was like yeah I mean that guy that hit
it though I was like he you know he I
you know what I want to do the right
thing I was in high I was in college I
had no money I had my Discover card on
me it had a 500 limit I remember it and
and uh Lethal Weapon 3 which was overdue
and which was overdue and that's per day
per day so you got it you got really got
it again they charge you a full rental
yeah a full rental price yeah yeah
anyway uh so I go I I I I guess I could
try to help and I gave my Discover card
he goes how much would you like to put
on that and I was like
25 and he rang twenty five dollars on my
Discover card and then he said hold on
he went in put the guy to sleep came out
gave me the death certificate so you
have the dead cat's Death Stick too and
it felt I felt really bad and it was
like a formal little thing they do and
on the name it said stray and I just to
this day I really feel you still have
the death certificate I'm sure I have it
because I [__] save everything we
should get the death certificate the
dead goldfish all the dead animal things
you have you should get it and put in a
certain area of your home
this is the dead animal zone of your
house oh that's a great idea why not
right I think that's a nice idea we'll
film it you know what you know you know
it's perfect to put patreon yeah we'll
go check the patreon yeah that's what
we'll have yeah I um yeah no I I think
when you kill an animal you see here's
are you coming back as a bird I'm gonna
come back as a bird but let me tell you
what's that Condor what's condor
it's a condor it's a condor you never
hear about a condor right no you're
about a hawk yeah you hear about a a
vulture those are disgusting they eat
dead bodies
an eagle an eagles called very American
what bird lives the longest are those
big like predator birds
due to Condors is so you know that
they're bringing back uh
um uh
the What bird are they bringing back
from the dinosaur age they're no they're
bringing it but not a pterodactyl
They're bringing back the dodo bird
and the woolly mammoth was and The
Woolly map but the dodo bird is
officially back oh then we kind of
stopped saying that
you can't say like he's he he went out
like the dodo bird no no that's the
whole thing another thing yeah really
yeah
he's like the the dodo bird the way he
went the way of the dodo bird people say
that which is like he's not around
anymore because the dodo bird really
does look like what you would think a
Dodo is it's got a [__] shitty what
does a dodo bird look like a dodo bird
it's got no yeah I got no Sigma H man
one no signal and said is it on
yeah the TV's kind of talking [__] it's
like is it are you even on
um hey dumbass
here we go here we go we got Venetia
pressing the buttons vanity is also
hungover so is pimp pimps on Edibles we
had great Edibles at the premiere party
we had the premier party from my vice
show last night at Joy face food
sandwiches catered by Joe DeRosa he's
got new sandwiches at Joey Rose
and they are phenomenal it's called it's
a cold chicken cutlet it's oh is it cold
yeah but it is phenomenal that chicken
what's on that [__] chicken cutlet
cheese some type of special sauce right
it was awesome I forget but it was good
that I I ate like five of them that was
good and then uh and then uh and Joe
Joey Rose is uh I said this on on uh on
another episode but Joey Rose I think is
the only person in history to uh cater
the premiere party for the TV show he's
a part of I don't think anyone's ever
done that in history
sandwiches to the show that he was home
oh yeah
the donor board is wild dodo Bird's
coming back so do you think my question
to you is do you you think that a they
will bring back dinosaurs and we're
living in that time or B they already
have and they just keep it in a secret
place oh man you think they genetically
engineered dinosaurs well if they can
get dodo birds what would be the point
of them genetically engineering a
dinosaur to one end tourism same thing
as Jurassic Park the woolly mammoth's
gonna come back and they're building
like a zoo in Antarctica to kind of keep
them to see what happens I don't know
it's confusing oh zoo in Antarctica oh
because woolly mammoth yeah but a woolly
mammoth I mean is still same thing but I
mean
[__] around with a T-Rex yeah you
feel like it's you know it's it's two
dollars off for seniors and children
under five you're not gonna do that no
would you guys eat dinosaur
[Music]
it was fried it tastes like fried yeah
yeah yeah I had alligator once mine it
tasted like a like a chicken like it
just kind of tasted like you're about to
Alligator they found in Prospect Park
yeah emaciated yeah someone just dumped
it in there they had it as a pet I think
it was like less than like 70 of its
weight it's a shame they also found a
bathroom stopper in his stomach really
yeah damn a bathroom
door no no like the the
um the bathtub stop I like that like a
bathtub drain the drain plug like an
internal butt plug like it was caught
well I I don't think it was an internal
alligator butt plug but it was
definitely the plug that you stopped the
drain with a dodo bird is you know
people used to as an insult you don't my
mom would say that sometimes
this guy's a real dodo bird it's weird
it's weird because you know it's
interesting that parents do that because
my dad used to call people turkeys he
was like your turkey I love you you call
people turkey and then we call people
snowballs
turkey he'd be like this guy's a
freaking turkey snowball over here I
don't know but he would call people a
turkey is that like that he predate
snowflake
wow maybe he did but I know he would
call people turkeys all the time like a
fat white guy called the snowball well
we want a snowball no he just uh like
somebody cuts him off in traffic he'd
either call him a turkey or a snowball
that's really funny yeah snowball that's
pretty funny turkey's great calling
somebody and Nancy's funny too
um what did he what did this guy say on
I heard this guy insult someone he goes
oh I heard this guy go uh he was
fighting with some guy in the street and
the guy walked around he went get out of
here short stack
fundamentally change about penguin might
be nice here's the thing it's I used to
for a long time and I'm just going to be
honest with you because that's the thing
when you change your style you change
your look you get a little bit more
honest
what I've you feel more closer to your
true self yes I think it's who I've
always been okay
what what I I used to not that everyone
see animals hurt or anything like that
but I I would look at you know when I
had my daughter the a cat you know the
the cat that that Jasmine had had for
years before she even met me you know it
I was worried that that cat was gonna
strip one of us and we were gonna drop
our daughter and I was like I don't care
about animals I just care about my child
get the cat away from my daughter it's
not a part of our family it's an animal
it doesn't matter my feelings on that
have fundamentally changed I now feel
connected to every living thing in this
world that we are just happen to be
alive as a human form they're alive as a
cat form that's alive as a tree form and
we're all kind of sharing so you feel
like you've been enlightened because of
your fashion change yes I feel like I've
been enlightened enlightened because uh
yeah because of of dressing like you
know Robert De Niro and Goodfellas yeah
Jimmy Conway but but I think that I do
feel strongly now not that I want a pet
in the house but I to say that so and so
is you know uh uh you know they're
saying their cat or dog is their child
and it's really not it is to some people
it is and that's just and you have to
just be okay with them yeah because
we're all on this planet we're all we're
all sharing the same energy of the
planet uh one time uh like 20 years ago
Gatto used to live in Queens and he had
an apartment with my other friend Joe
the fish are you saying uh Joe Joe the
fish and then Joe Gatto which is cat in
Spanish yes yeah Gatto comes home one
day he spends he blows like three grand
on an African gray parrot out of nowhere
he comes home he's got a [__] parrot
that lives 80 years commitment and he's
got the cage for it and the whole setup
was three grand and this is 20 years ago
when we're not making that kind of money
yeah and I I go I get to his house and
he goes I want to show you something
what I got and he goes into his office
there's a cage like literally six feet
high and then it is a goddamn bird that
big I go what the [__] is that he goes
this is an African gray parrot I go why
he goes I I saw it and it's fun I go
what does it do he goes learn up to 1200
words
I swear to Christ it lives 80 years
it'll learn for 1200 words here's the
caveat if it catches a draft it dies
really if he leaves the window open and
the [__] catches a draft he'll walk and
it'll be dead in the morning it lives 80
years in case it lets us a cold draft in
the room okay he had the thing like
three years the thing attacked me he had
the he had to apparently he had the
wings clipped right but I would walk by
and the thing would he would take it out
and put it on top of the cage so it
could have like yeah be free out there
right so I would walk by and was in the
hallway I walk by and I would look and
every time I looked it just lunged at me
and it would try it would fly but his
wings were clipped so it would make it
like five feet I would scream I swear to
God and move and it would hit the wall
he gave it away for free about three
years later after three years the
thing's supposed to learn 1200 words the
only thing he did was go
that's it that's it
not a [__] word not one syllable
three grand on and if it gets a draft
it's dead 80 years did lifespan if it
gets the draft it dies do you think it's
alive right now
I mean it would only be 20 years old can
you imagine that it's all it's a kid
it's it's j it's just about to get if it
has fake ID yeah yeah yeah it's
literally a kid can you Google African
gray parrot yeah I want to see what this
looks like I'm like that's a bad
investment like you imagine there we go
African gray 70 years and all of a
sudden it catches the draft is this what
it looked like when you yeah so it's
[__] what it looked like yeah wow
yeah no I don't know I yeah Maximus
that's a good name yeah it's solid and
an app would you eat parrot
when I was little parakeets with a ray
oh what a yeah parakeet parakeets is a
parakeet a small like like a like a
miniature version of a parent I don't
think it grows up to be a parent I think
it's like an offshoot of a parrot and
they do tweet tweet tweet and then you
have to put the you have to put the you
have to put the uh the freaking Shades
down at night otherwise it doesn't go to
sleep it won't go to sleep have to drop
a shade over it so that it gets dark so
it knows to shut the shut up really yeah
otherwise that thing will tweet into the
night all day yeah now I can't believe
we went an hour into this episode
without acknowledging that yesterday was
International women's day and I want to
just give a just give a quick uh Happy
International Women's Day to all the
international women out there yeah
Venetia our moms
that just doesn't mean worldwide women
it means in women that aren't here
I think it means well people
International women
so not National it's not counting
Americans I thought International women
just meant worldwide like everybody yeah
because aren't we International to
people not non-nation right but we're
sitting in our nation so I'm wondering
if to us it we're saying happy
International women's day to
non-american women meaning we are
because we're they're not International
here but over there they're wishing
hours somebody in Canada you can't wish
your women here in international women
no uh we're I'm I'm in I'm International
to someone in Canada or Mexico so they
might be wishing our women happy you
know International women's day but we
can't you know what I mean but vanity is
is it America citizen living here vanity
is Greek but that's her that's her
ethnicity not her nationality by the way
she's dual citizenship dual citizenship
so you do get it you're one of the few
that live here and get it and you get it
to Europe International flying it's
applying to one passport of yours right
this happy International and buy
multiple passports and stuff oh wow it
would be like a spy she is like a spy
yeah and by the way I can't believe we
went 20 30 minutes with the Sham with
the sheep lamb conversation and we
didn't ask Venetia the Greek who is a
professional with sheep and lamb I'll
use Quick oh yeah what about it what's
the difference between sheep and lamb
that's a great question you don't know I
don't know what about a goat
I don't know a goat is not the same
goater in the hills and you pet them and
they'd eat garbage do you know what
grandmother is in Greek
it's a fun one okay yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think Yaya is the
best grandmother name yeah yeah that's
so fun I believe this fun grandmas
Nanny no Grammy it's fine Yaya yeah we
call we call my grandmother a bunching
it well my mom's side we called her
nanny when we're little but a lot of my
cousins call it Graham Dukes Graham and
that's the name Graham Duke it's not her
name her name is Lydia but right right
shout out Graham my grandma by the way I
just turned 92. by the way the two best
old people names for a woman Lydia for a
man George George and Lydia that's her
Grandpa that's a powerful grandparent
couple I love Lydia
George I gotta come around on
our next guest tank Sinatra's real name
is George is it really yeah oh you might
have said that let's talk to him about
it I want to talk to you about how he's
got he's got an old ass man's name okay
we're feeling good I feel good I feel um
I I feel uh
I feel good I I I'm gonna be honest with
you I woke up this morning I was still
actively drunk from the night before
yeah
um but I feel like I did what I could I
still feel like I have energy
um but I didn't know all yet no I'm not
hitting the wall but I'm starting to get
a headache where I just know that it's
it's I drank too much hydrating I
haven't seen to drink a sip
okay is that coffee
I don't think that's gonna do it
this actually yeah coffee anything
that's not water dehydrates you how far
how Wild is that anything that's not
water actually dehydrated from a
molecular point of view because I read
somewhere that now they're saying
there's water in every drink and if
you're drinking another drink there's
still water in it you're still getting
hydrated well the information you got is
bogus okay okay it and I'm telling you
if you're not drinking any anything
that's a diuretic as well no
yeah so you're gonna do Peeps I'm going
to do Peeps now I'm less hydrated do we
have water in here Venetia vanity has
gone water uh this pipe's in here we can
do it get water why the hell not yeah
I'll check here's the here's here's
here's what you need to know about me
I'm a guy I will still to this day drink
from any faucet in New York City if you
get me a cup I drink from this bathroom
faucet no problem not even think twice
about it but I will not eat a blueberry
that's one day expired wow that's how I
roll just because blueberries it can be
suspect because you can look in there
and see a whole bunch of good ones but
there's still old jacked ones in there
right like one could be perfect and one
could have all that [__] on it and you
don't know you just oh toss them in your
mouth and you want to just be
willy-nilly about it right you want to
be will nil when you eat the bloops
right you're going to get a bad bloop so
I understand why you do that this has
been hey babe
Don't Be Afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe
[Music]